david sur quoi portent les débats cet
après midi eh bien écoutez 1 depuis 16h
les dépasse poursuivant concernant ce
projet de loi et sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire un première séance à 16
heures la deuxième aura lieu à 21h peu
de députés présents au sein de
l'hémicyle faire une motion de rejet
préalable à d'ores et déjà été déposée
par le parti socialiste concernant ce
projet doit qui ne signifie pas un
retour à la vie normale mais qui ne fait
que consolider les pouvoirs de
l'exécutif un selon leurs mots fait
l'objectif pour le gouvernement est en
effet de desserrer le corset de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire prolongé jusqu'au 31
octobre 2021
tout en restant vigilants afin socomie
en clair les députés vont voter pour le
calendrier de réouverture un souhaité
par emmanuel macron lors de son
allocution en avril dernier et le vrai
débat vous l'avez dit un porte sur
l'article 1er qui contient plus d'une
centaine à d'amendements il concerne le
fameux pass sanitaire une mesure
largement décriée par l'opposition mais
aussi par certains à députés issus de la
majorité initialement prévu pour voyager
à l'étranger le gouvernement entend de
fer entend faire de ce document l'un des
instruments premier du déconfinement ils
pourraient être stockés sur la plaque
l'application mobile a tous senti qu
vide elle les contours de ce pass
inquiète
on peut aller bourbon puisqu'il sera
nécessaire pour accéder à certains lieux
publics à plusieurs députés parlent de
discrimination écouter eric coquerel
député la france insoumise on nous avait
dit au départ rien qu'aux frontières et
puis maintenant il ya un amendement du
gouvernement très mal fichu toulon
l'audi puisqu'on nous dit ça va
concerner les rassemblons loisirs de
foire lorsque pourquoi ça il ya droit et
pas par exemple les rassemblements liés
à des questions de travail ou des
questions du culte et hautement déjà
bizarre
et puis en plus de sa société qui
commencent à contrôler et surveiller
discriminer ces citoyens de d'après
leurs états de santé présumé bas j'ai
pas très envie de vie dedans donc c'est
un vrai choix qui fait et quand le
gouvernement dit qu'une fois qu'il va
être mis en place c'est pas pour
généraliser moi je n'en crois rien du
tout je crois pas du tout que le jour où
il sera mis en place
qu'est ce que le gouvernement dira un
restaurateur par exemple qui vous dirai
ce que vous avez votre pass sanitaire si
vous voulez pas le montrer c'est moi
mais monsieur mais je ne je ne vous je
ne vous ouvre pas les portes du
restaurant personnes donc j'ai bien peur
qu'on mette le doigt dans un engrenage
extraordinairement dangereux pour les
libertés et qu'il n'a aucune preuve de
doc et de fiabilité d'appeler sanitaires
beaucoup d'inquiétude du côté de la
majorité on préfère contre balancer on
estime que ce pass est née sanitaire est
nécessaire qui doit être affiné à
l'heure de son un examen aujourd'hui un
deux séances au programme je le rappelle
la présidente de la commission des lois
yale brebis v souhaite ajouter des
garde-fous à ce projet devrait coûter
pour moi la bonne mesure c'est ça c'est
considérer que le pass and iter est
réservé pour les grands événements les
événements exceptionnels et que pour les
évènements qui doivent s'improviser qui
ressort vraiment de la vie quotidienne
qui doivent pouvoir être vécu comme
étant réalisée sur un coup de tête je
veux dans un restaurant je vais dans un
cinéma
je dois pouvoir le faire sont organisées
sans le prévoir et dont le sang pour la
plupart de nos concitoyens allait faire
un test pcr que ce qu'aujourd'hui la
plupart de nos concitoyens ne sont pas
encore vaccinés donc il faut qu'on
puisse avoir
voilà toutes ces actions d'impulsion
doivent pouvoir se faire sans passé ni
terre c'est vraiment très important et
il est également très important que les
personnes privées telles que les
restaurateurs les propriétaires de
cinéma de théâtre etc
il est très important qu'ils sachent
qu'ils ne pourront pas demander à leurs
clients un passionné terre ils ne
pourront pas en faire un argument
commercial
il ne faut pas que ce pass sanitaire
s'insère dans la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens encadrer son utilité éviter
son usage quotidien dans les restaurants
cinémas ou autres lieux publics vous
l'avez entendu si l'objectif premier des
députés aujourd'hui pour ne pas porter
atteinte aux libertés fondamentales et
que se passe nous devienne pas un frein
pour les français mais du côté
mais pour l'opposition en tout cas c'est
très mal parti mercy et david khalifa
pour toutes ces précisions ont direct
donc du palais bourbon à paris